jean pierre guéno historiens bonjour
jean pierre guéno merci d'être en direct
avec nous vous trouvez donc dans nos
studios de caumartin alors on sait qu'il
n'ya pas vraiment de projet vise et on
va dire de reconfiguration des relations
en tout cas aux configurations radhika
des relations entre moscou et washington
on sait que barack obama mais aussi
george bush avait tenté justement de
mettre à plat leurs relations qui
étaient tendus
est ce qu'aujourd'hui il s'agit
seulement de poser on va dire les bases
d'une nouvelle relation froide mais
pragmatique
oui on devrait retrouver des relations
diplomatiques plus fluide souvent les
apparences dans un contexte dont vous ne
cessez de rappeler qu'il est qu'il est
très jeune lourd et est chargé de nuages
alors c'est intéressant ce qu'on vient
de voir parce que la poignée de main
aura duré deux secondes
elle n'a pas la force la durée de la
poignée de mains de 1985 cet état à
genève
c'était le choc reagan gorbatchev on
était à 6 ans delà de la fin de l'urss
et on célébrait d'une certaine façon le
dégel c'était la grande conférence du
dégel à cette époque la poignée de main
reagan gorbatchev avait duré sept
secondes
alors il nous faut revenir en arrière il
ya trois autres face à face entre les
américains et les russes qu'il est
important de resituer par rapport à ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui
d'abord 1943 c'est la conférence de
téhéran
et elle est importante cette conférence
puisque les trois grands staline
roosevelt churchill se retrouver en
terrine le principe du
démembrement de l'allemagne du partage
de l'europe
et puis va entériner le projet de
débarquement en normandie pour juin 44
qui peut oublier une autre conférence
qui est celle de yalta en 45 qui est
également très importante
à nouveau on retrouve à face à face
entre roosevelt et staline et cette
conférence va avoir beaucoup
d'importance pour l'avenir pour le
déplacement des frontières entre la
pologne et la russie pour l'évolution
des relations mais j'ai l'idée de
d'évoquer une autre un autre face à face
c'est peut-être le fou rire le plus
tragique de l'histoire
on est en 95 on n'est pas à genève
comment 85
on est à new york et en 85 il y à un
face à face entre bob bill clinton et
mauricette spleen et en fin de compte il
vient d'y avoir un constat d'échec en
réalité c'est à dire qu'il faut mettre
en place une force de paix on est un
mois après la fin de la guerre de bosnie
herzégovine et il va y avoir une boutade
de boris eltsine
je cite je suis plus optimiste repartant
ici que lorsque je suis arrivé dit il
après mon discours dié vous annoncer que
ma rencontre avec bill clinton serait un
désastre c'est vous les journalistes qui
est l'un des aphtes et alors cette île
chambre la presse alors que les deux
hommes viennent d'aboutir à un semi
échec puisqu'il n'arrive pas à se mettre
d'accord pour positionner la russie dans
la force de paix qui va se mettre en
place
hélas cette boutade qui chambrent
l'apref va déclencher un des plus
terribles ou fou rire d'eux
de l'histoire de ces relations ont
nourri tous encore parce qu'on a oublié
tout ce que je viens d il faut quand
même rappeler que si tu un mois après la
fin de la guerre bonne mrgreen hier qui
a fait cent mille morts qui a déclenché
l'afflux de réfugiés de deux ou trois
millions de réfugiés viol collectif
massacre c'est quelque chose
d'absolument épouvantable c'est fou rire
est bon on n'est pas du tout dans le
même contexte les relations sont plus
tendues il n'y aura pas de fous rires
cette fois ci c'est fou rire il faut
rappeler notre fou rire quand hitler
gesticuler dans les années 30 on ne
prenait pas au sérieux et ses
gesticulations déclenchait une certaine
hilarité comme comme en 95 pour ce que
je viens de citer
on peut se demander si cette réaction
des opinions publiques qu'elles soient
suscité par le déni ou par la peur ne
sont pas en fait
la crainte la peur d'ouvrir la boîte de
pandore et de regarder en face les
situations géopolitiques internationales
voilà justement est ce que en tant
qu'historien vous pensez que finalement
aujourd'hui l'histoire est un éternel
recommencement vous parliez justement de
ces entretiens en 1943 45 et puis entre
maurice et le signer et bill clinton il
y avait à l'époque une guerre froide qui
étaient ouvertes déclarée entre ces deux
puissances entre l'urss à l'époque les
états unis aujourd'hui
voilà on sent que il y a comme un air de
déjà vu entre la russie et les etats
unis
oui en même temps c'est très différent
il s'agit on s'achemine vers une autre
forme de guerre froide plus technique
plus virtuel on voit les procès
d'intention ou les moules les
accusations qui sont portées de part et
d'autre on sait ce qui s'est passé avec
des hackers russes dans les campagnes
électorales
l'américaine on sait qu'aujourd'hui vous
le rappeliez tout à l'heure le contexte
qui fait que joe biden viennent se
rapprocher de l'europe et de l'otan donc
à cet égard la russie est un peu isolé
et puis le vrai problème actuellement 2
dans l'immédiat la véritable urgence de
joe biden il peut pas se battre sur tous
les fronts à la fois c'est à la fois
essayez d'en terminer avec le co vide et
puis c'est surtout la chine qui est qui
qui paraît beaucoup plus préoccupante
c'est là que sur ses priorités
donc il faut pas attendre de miracle de
ce face à face dans quelques heures mais
simplement le retour à une certaine
normalisation des relations
on n'est plus du tout au stade où on
était avec donald trump l'imprévisible
inénarrable l'ingérable donald trump
on est là dans quelque chose qui devrait
se normaliser davantage
merci beaucoup en tout cas jean pierre
guéno d'avoir été notre invité ce matin